-Congrats on everything, dude.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
I was going to
tell the story about --
Oh, I'll just say it real quick.
Years ago, breaking plates
with Drew Brees...
Remember that? In Indianapolis?
It was Taylor versus Drew Brees
and at this giant theater
in Indianapolis.
And the idea is,
I'm going to throw plates
and whoever breaks them,
first one to three wins.
So it's a famous quarterback,
Drew Brees, to the Saints...
-He's alright.
-...and Taylor.
So Taylor goes first,
pressure's on him.
I throw the plate.
You break
the plate immediately.
Great. Drew's turn.
I throw the plate.
He misses the plate.
Second plate,
I throw it for you.
You hit it immediately.
Drew Brees stops laughing.
[ Laughter ]
You've never seen anyone
switch it on.
-He changed.
-I'll never forget it.
He was like -- [ Laughs ]
[ Laughter ]
And then at one point,
I couldn't even
let go of the plate.
-Yeah.
-I go, "Just stop.
I just don't want to play
the game anymore."
He was like someone
throwing something at me.
I was like -- And he, like,
ended up winning.
But it was like an athlete
just turning it on.
But I'll never forget.
That was such a fun moment.
-So fun.
-Pull!
[ Drumroll ]
Yeah!
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Drumroll ]
-Pull!
-Oh!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Oh!
-Alright, here we go.
Sudden death. Sudden death.
[ Drumroll ]
-Pull!
-Oh!
-[ Laughs ]
-Whoops.
[ Sad notes play ]
Oh, give me a break.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I didn't want to
take your head off.
I'm sorry.
-Sorry, sorry.
-Alright.
Here we go.
[ Drumroll ]
Pull!
-Oh!
-Drew Brees for the win!
[ Drumroll ]
-Pull!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Drew Brees! Taylor Lautner!